multiplying two three-digit numbers is
so easy provided you know the best way
to do it 211 times 301 try it out okay I
don't know how you did it but let's see
how much time I take 1 times 1 is 1
1 plus 0 is 1 2 plus 0 plus 3 is 5 3
plus 0 is 3 and 2 times 3 is 6 that's
our answer
63,000 511 didn't take much time did I
let's erase this first how did we get
the answer so quick the concept is very
simple first we multiply these two
numbers 1 multiplied by 1 is 1 let me
take this arrow to the extreme right
next we find the sum of this product and
this one 1 multiplied by 1 is 1 and 1
multiplied by 0 is 0 1 plus 0 is 1 we
take this cross to the right as well
just so that we remember what we did we
multiplied these two numbers first and
then added these two products you can
probably guess the next step find the
sum of these 3 products 2 times 1 plus 1
times 0 plus 1 times 3 that equals 5 we
shift this to the right and then we add
these two products 2 times 0 plus 1
times 3 it equals 3 and then we just
find this product 2 times 3 is 6 and we
take the arrow to the right 60 3511
confused you shouldn't be look at the
pattern 1 2 3 2 1 we counter the number
of arrows do you know what this pattern
is called it's called a palindrome it's
a sequence of characters which reads the
same backward or forward 1 2 3
two one one two three two one
Madame is another example of a
palindrome ma da m and M a da m in the
same way try multiplying 371 with 433
okay
first we multiply one with three it
equals three then we write the sum of
this product and this 121 plus three is
twenty-four we write a four here and
carry the two over remember it's one two
three two one so we find the sum of
these three products 1 multiplied by 4
is 4 7 times 3 is 21 and 3 times 3 is 9
the sum is 34 4 & 3 carried over and
then the sum of these 2 product 9 plus
28 is 37 we write a 7 and a 3 on top and
the last product is 3 times 4 which
equals 12 3 4 2 plus 4 is 6 3 plus 7 is
10 0 and a 1 carried over 1 plus 3 plus
2 is 6 and we write the 1 here 371 times
433 equals 160 thousand six hundred and
forty-three it becomes so easy with the
palindrome approach one two three two
one will this palindrome approach work
for the product of two four-digit
numbers absolutely it will be
two three four three two and A one yes
this is a palindrome as well we will
look at a couple of examples of
multiplying two four digit numbers in
the next session